welcome to this video playing kanji MO
and he doesn't have a flag so you don't
know where this guy is coming from go
Kings Indian trying to play the
classical again which leads to sharp
games he's playing this 98 line one of
those super aggressive ways to play it
where black is really yeah Black is
really am throwing caution to the winds
just going to check him hmm yeah mm-hmm
do I go Bishop g4 or not okay it's one
of those cases normally f4 is not
considered to be that great before White
has played f3 because of this move but
it is this is a time-consuming thing the
special gphone
yeah i mean i can actually take now
continue okay Gahee baby has let's do
this here not not clear if I need a
three but probably yes
yeah without the light squared Bishop
white um has less defensive problems
this is quite clear so root comes to g6
taking is not really advisable here I
wonder how to do this maybe age three
first just keeping this under control
okay I can't let's let's get this going
now g6 surprised me a little bit i
thought the rookwood go to g6 trying to
prepare the g4 push a little more but he
did not do that at all
if I go be five soon hmm okay so he's
pushing ultimately but I really have a
hard time to believe that they can just
jettison the porn like that
cannot even move any of those pieces it
doesn't look good night 8th 5s even a
move here just attacking b7 and night XP
7 is a pretty big threat ok so to do
that so for the c6 maybe then night
night should be seven it looks funny I
had a strong though it is that's
actually strong if he takes Knight X
it's over and be 697 is also very nice
he only has Queenie 7 and then I go
Queen d7 and that's the day that did
basically I get Queens traded and Queen
takes pawn takes the 7s kind of funny he
cannot prevent the capture on da door
the promotion yeah I can just trade
queens now and going to going to be
winning now so let's do it right let's
go a5 and term
winning on the queenside um he doesn't
even have a shade of counter play him
night
yeah wonder many ways to do it night be
five in fact isms night be five ay 6a be
six takes on b5 however it looks kind of
fancy okay let's just play it in the
simple way Knight takes t-6s also not
bad at all but okay do we need to rush
anything here that's that test to go
back
I could have played this much better I'm
pretty sure night on B sound looks kind
of odd now can I didn't play that well
at all night is trying to come to g5
okay I need to open this can't get the
King here I'm taking yeah I mean I
played it a bit a bit lackluster here
after the initial moves here with the
night on b7 now reside it was just just
terribly bad for black just just the
case yeah after the light squared Bishop
gets traded Blacks game is very
difficult he really has problems without
this piece yeah okay this is Kenda Liam
and here i was really surprised 96 I was
thinking this is his idea trying to
prepare g4 and it didn't even think that
is this is so clear because this Bishop
g4 Bishop takes the eight business it is
strategically desirable but it costs
time so I wasn't totally sure about all
that a g6 a form you should back yeah
angie was just this is just desperate 95
yeah this is funny now ya hear here why
does certainly strategically winning but
I made mistakes here I shouldn't play on
the capture to be honest this doesn't
look right
this is not good I should go back him
that's just more flexible and it keeps
the night be five idea alive attacking
this pawn is probably better okay the
way it went here here yeah I think g3 is
necessary if I give him the time to her
hopes go to g5 I might have some issues
here but yeah I think I'm pretty pretty
clearly winning now again the King goes
back and well he should still in inman
big trouble here with no space and then
the bed bishop and so on yeah this is
simply the whole line here with this 98
is very risky like typically does not
play a for a place Knight f6 in this
position and after f3f form nights ii 4g
for this just you have this kind of
thing is happening with a super-sharp
game where why does winning really on
the queenside but can easily be
checkmated on the other side okay i hope
you like this thanks for watching